hello welcome uh this afternoon my name
is barbara stone and i will be talking
to you today about the future of mouse
embryo transfer achieving the three
hours with the nsaid device
during the talk if you have any
questions that you would like to have us
address
please feel free to
uh
log a question and we will get to the um
question and answer session at the end
of the
webinar
first i'd like to talk to you a little
bit about what is embryo transfer quite
simply it's the removal of embryos from
a donor animal and placement of those
embryos into a recipient
both surgical and non-surgical methods
are available and the use of embryo
transfer allows
researchers to perform manipulations in
embryos for research
and these manipulations occur in vitro
embryo manipulations in mice are used
for generating genetically modified mice
they're used for
re-derivation or removal of pathogens
from mice
for breeding purposes and also for
recovery of strains including
and after disasters order for storage
purposes
some common embryo
procedures include dna micro injection
prior preservation of embryos in vitro
fertilization
and also embryonic stem cell-based
transgenesis
regardless of the techniques that are
used embryos must be transferred to a
suitable recipient for development
traditional mouse embryo transfer
methods have been surgical so um why
exactly is there a need for non-surgical
methods
and as you probably know russell and
birch define the three r's in their book
the principles of humane experimental
technique
the three r's are an ethical framework
for animal use and scientific
experimentation
they include replacement of animal
models
reduction in the number of animals used
and refinement
of techniques
of
for example reducing pain and improving
animal welfare an example of a
refinement in the technique is the
non-surgical embryo transfer
procedure
there are several methods for embryo
transfer in mice
oviduct surgery is used for early stage
embryos
uterine surgery is used for morula and
blastocyst stage embryos and
non-surgical embryo transfer can also be
used for morula and blastocyst stage
embryos
non-surgical embryo transfer with the
nsaid device is a three hours refinement
technique that reduces stress in mice
what i'd like to show you here is that
the nsaid procedure is effective for
embryo transfer of blastocysts
and blastocysts were transferred to the
uterine horn of 2.5 days post-coitus or
dpc pseudo-pregnant female cd1 mice
the pregnancy rate shown here
um
is uh the percent of females becoming
pregnant after embryo transfer
and the birth rate is the percent of
embryos transferred to females that
become pregnant
and for the non-surgical embryo transfer
uh procedure you can see that the
pregnancy rate is approximately
82 percent and the birth rate
is
46 percent
so while non-surgical embryo transfer is
effective for embryo transfer
the question remains is it does it meet
the criteria of a three r's refinement
so in order to determine this first we
tested induction of stress hormone uh
hormones during surgical and
non-surgical embryo transfer
we were able to determine that stress
hormone levels are
higher in response to surgery than
non-surgical transfer
now for example if you have a stressor
such as pain
it will signal the hypothalamus to make
corticosterotropin releasing hormone
which then begins a cascade resulting in
the release of corticosterone
this cascade can affect heart rate lung
function and other things and generates
a an overall stress response
corticosterone levels can be measured
either in the blood or in the feces
and um here we chose to measure fecal
corticosterone levels
and this is a full increase in
corticosterone levels here on the left
pickle samples were collected from
pseudopregnant female mice at 2.5 days
post-coitum and assigned to five
experimental groups
the first experimental group is a
control group and then a non-surgical
embryo transfer group
a surgical
transfer group
also has controls non-surgical embryo
transfer performed with anesthesia and
anesthesia control
corticosterone levels in fecal samples
were measured by elisa assay
and as you can see indicated by the red
bars
the
corticosterone levels were significantly
increased in mice three to six hours
post surgical
transfer but there was no significant
increase for non-surgical embryo
transfer or for any
of the controls
next we tested cardiac responses to the
surgical and non-surgical procedures
we used electrocardiograms and
electrocardiograms are recordings of the
electrical currents that pass through
the heart and signify the activity
associated with each heartbeat
the non-invasive ec genie instrument for
mouse specifics was used to record these
electrocardiograms from mice without
restraint or with without any surgical
implants
readings were made by placing the mouse
on a sensory pad
outfitted with three monitoring
electrodes
the cardiac activity was measured
passively through the pause
in this experiment
heart heart beats per minute
are graphed
at various hours post procedure
for
again the 2.5
dpc pseudo pregnant cd1 mice
data was analyzed by mouse specifics
using ecg
ezcg analysis software
and what you can see here is actually
an anesthesia effect and that
the mice that were
either that either had surgery performed
on them or were anesthesia controls or
inset with anesthesia controls all had a
decrease in the number of heartbeats per
minute
by 38 to 50 percent whereas the end set
procedure and the
no procedure control did not alter the
heartbeats per minute
variability in beatsbeat rhythm of the
heart is measured as a coefficient of
variance and here we have the
coefficient of variance graphed at
various hours post procedure again for
the pseudo-pregnant cd1 mice
and what this shows
is that
variability in cardiac rhythm is
significantly increased by eight percent
for the surgical group but not for any
of the other groups that were tested
so in conclusion
uh the nsa procedure is effective for
uterine transfer of blastocyst stage
embryos
the surgery uh causes a significant
increase in the levels of the stress
hormone corticosterone whereas the
insect procedure does not
anesthesia
also causes a 38 to 50 percent decrease
in the number of heartbeats per minute
whereas the nsaid procedure does not
alter heartbeats per minute
and last the surgery uh increases
cardiac variability by 8
whereas anesthesia alone and the enzyme
procedure do not significantly increase
cardiac variability
uh use of the nsaid device is therefore
less stressful to the mice than a
surgical embryo transfer
and as such
it is a successful alternative to a
surgical procedure
and a three hours refinement for a
currently used technique
so what are some of the applications to
embryo transfer that uh non-surgical
embryo transfer is applicable for
we've tested um
uh non-surgical embryo transfer
non-surgical embryo transfer with
embryos that have been manipulated in
various ways prior to transfer
and we we have shown that enzo can be
used to transfer micro injected embryos
now these embryos are
this this graph is a comparison of the
transfer efficiency between embryos
transferred by surgical and non-surgical
methods
after injection of a variety of
different trans genes in this case five
different transgenes were used
for surgical transfer the micro injected
uh embryos were transferred to the
oviduct or in oviduct surgery
into 0.5 dpc pseudopregnant female mice
for non-surgical transfer however the
micro injected embryos needed to be
cultured to blast at this stage prior to
transfer
and these were then transferred to the
uterine horn into 2.5 day post
coital
pseudopregnant recipients
the transfer efficiency as you can see
is similar between the two methods
and the number of transgenic pups
recovered after the procedure is also
very similar
non-surgical embryo transfer can also be
used to transfer embryos generated by in
vitro fertilization
this graph shows that
the pregnancy rate and the birth rate
for non-surgical embryo transfer
ivf of fresh oocytes from b6 c3f1 female
mice and cryopreserved sperm from b6 e3
f1 males
was performed
fertilized embryos were then cultured in
ksom media to blast assist stage and
transferred into 2.5 days
pseudo-pregnant females
transfer of the ivf derived blastocyst
resulted in about a 60 pregnancy rate
and a 43 percent
birth rate
for ivf
insect can also be used to
transfer cryopreserved embryos here
cryopreserved b6 c3f1 one cell embryos
were cultured to blast assist in ksi
media and transferred again to 2.5 day
pseudo-pregnant cd1 recipients
the transfer of the cryopreserved
embryos resulted in a 50
pregnancy rate and a
39
uh birth rate
for this experiment
non-surgical embryo transfer can also be
used to transfer embryos after esl
injections um this data is courtesy of
the micro injection service at
the jackson laboratories
here c57 black six
blastocysts were injected with jm8 a3 n1
es cells
and
then they were transferred into the 2.5
day pseudo-pregnant
cby b6 f1j recipients
in this experiment the pregnancy rate
from uh nsaid transfers of esl injected
blastocyst was the pregnancy rate was 80
the birth rate was
uh
31
and the rate of the total rate of
chimerism of a number of chimeras
per
the number of pups surviving to weaning
was 54
we've also been able to successfully
transfer
uh
sperm for artificial insemination with
the nsaid device and so here um i'm
showing the
pregnancy rate for this experiment was
roughly 36 percent
and the
picture on the right is a picture of the
result one of the resulting pups from
one of these experiments
uh in in
summary um the
artificial insemination experiment
actually was performed with uh super
ovulated females um
and the uh sperm delivery occurred on
the day after the second
hormone injection and
i'm not going to go over the specifics
of this particular experiment right now
but i will
be happy to cover that later if
anybody's interested
in conclusion
um the nsaid device can successfully
transfer embryos after micro injection
of dna when cultured blast is a stage
um
it can successfully transfer blastocyst
derived from in vitro fertilization
also blastocysts developed from
preserved early stage embryos
it can also transfer esl injected
blastocysts resulting in recovery of
chimeric pups
and it can also be used to transfer
sperm during artificial insemination
resulting in live births
a couple of other uses which we're not
going to be talking about today but
have been
referenced in the literature
is that you can also transfer pathogens
using the
non-surgical embryo transfer device
and other materials
for example con a coded
sepharose beads
drugs can be delivered this way
and a multitude of other materials that
can be used for research
this is a picture of the nsa device um
and the inset device is a teflon
catheter as uh
attached to a hub
which then attaches to a p2 pipette
which is used then for
delivery of specified
volumes of liquid
and as you can see here it is um
individually packaged an ethylene oxide
treated so that it can be used in
sterile environments
and this device actually also comes with
two specula in the ethylene oxide
treated package
which these of those
specula we'll be talking about in a
minute
the onset procedure and device that i'm
about to describe in detail was in was
invented by dr brett speer and michael
green at the university of kentucky
transgenic core facility
they
have described this in the literature
and there are three very simple steps to
this procedure
first of all
load the embryos into the device prepare
the recipient mouse and deliver the
embryos
to prepare the embryos
first the nsaid device is attached to a
p2 pipet
the embryos can then be loaded into the
pipet under
while watching under a microscope
up to 20 embryos can be loaded into the
inside device and 1.8 microliter of
media
the volume is then adjusted to 2
microliters to introduce a small bubble
into the bottom of the tip which helps
hold the liquid into the device
next the recipient mouse is prepared
a suitable female mouse is selected and
she needs to be 2.5 dpc pseudo-pregnant
the mouse is then held into position on
the cage top
a small speculum is inserted into the
vagina and then removed again and then a
larger speculum is inserted into the
vagina
at that point you can visually locate
the cervix
which there's a picture of the way that
the mouse is being held here shown here
and on the next slide you can see a
close-up
of a cd1 mouse
with the larger of the two nsaid specula
inserted and you can
hopefully you can see the cervix in
there and there's a small depression in
the center and that is what you would
aim the inset device at
next a video presentation of the
procedure will be
i've placed a 15 microliter drop of
media
under the lid of this petri dish and
i've loaded my embryos into it
now i'm taking the m set device
and i've set my p2 pipetman to 1.8
microliters
you simply place the
inset device onto the pipe batman
look into your microscope
bring the tip down
and slowly
release the plunger to load
the embryos once you've loaded the inset
then just dial up
to 2.00
microliters on your pipetman
this will introduce a small air bubble
at the tip and that'll help keep your
embryos from wicking out when they touch
the inside of the mouse until you get it
to where you're ready to expel the
embryos so the smaller piece of tubing
is used
to open up the vagina
just insert it briefly
pull it back out
now we're ready to insert the speculum
just uh insert the speculum
adjust your lighting so that you can see
down and you can actually
see
the cervical opening
pick up your inset device
insert into the mouse
until the hub touches
the speculum expel the embryos
remove the inset device
remove the speculum
and the procedure is complete
so um
if you'd like to see the video
demonstration again
um it can be seen on the peritects
website
also on the peritect's website are
complete instructions frequently asked
questions and helpful hints and tips
i can be contacted directly also by the
email address on this slide
i'd like to take a moment to mention a
few of the most important tips that we
have uh first of all removing the nsa
device from the uterine horn without
releasing the pipet plunger
is highly recommended
the nsa device itself was designed as a
single use device and so repeated use
will clog the inset tip with tissue
which could lead to unfavorable results
as always
inspection of the tip is good practice
just to make sure that the tip is not
bent when inserted into the mouse and
also that the
that any material hasn't clogged the tip
please do not use lubricants during this
procedure
they can clog the tip as well and they
are unneeded for
insertion of the specula
and please make sure
to read the nsaid instruction sheet
thoroughly before use
one of the most often asked questions is
which recipient stream should i use
and so we have just we have uh compared
a few different strains
that are used for
recipients as
during non-surgical embryo transfer
and this
graph shows strain dependent pregnancy
rates for embryo transfer methods
the pregnancy rate is shown on the left
and the various different strains are
indicated below
shown here are cd1 mice swiss webster
b6 cba f1s
c3hs
and c57 black six
also we've tested
uh
b6
d2 f1
recipients although not shown on this
graph
i will include the their results as well
what you can see is a comparison between
non-surgical embryo transfer and surgery
for each of these strains
and for the
if you look at the highest pregnancy
rates here you can see that the cd1
females the b6 cba f1 females and the
c3h females all have a very high rate of
pregnancy
the b62 f1s also had an 80
pregnancy rate and so they would be
included in the better group of embryo
recipients
on the next slide you can see strain
dependent birth rates for embryo
transfer methods and here the birth
rates indicated on the left the strain
is indicated on the bottom
and there's a comparison between
non-surgical embryo transfer and surgery
and what you can see here is that the
cd1
females
had the highest rate of the highest
birth rate shown at 46
the b6 g2 f1s also had a 44
birth rate and so we're also very high
so what we've concluded from this is
that many different strains can actually
be used as recipients for embryo
transfer
strains
in the labs are generally chosen for
convenience and ease of use a lot of
people try to use the strains that they
already have
and we've shown that it's possible to do
so
we recommend the 2.5
dpc cd1 pseudopregnant females
for recipients here
mostly for
well for three reasons first of all they
have the height one of the highest
pregnancy rates um also they have the
highest birth rate and they are
extremely docile and easy to handle and
so as such
we prefer to use them here
some of the other strains that have high
birth rates
and pregnancy rates
tend to be a little more
difficult to handle
and a lot of times aren't as good um
aren't as good mothers and so
we prefer to do those to use the cd ones
so some of the advantages of the nsaid
procedure itself
first and foremost it eliminates a
surgical procedure entirely so
there's no pain or distress to the
animals you can see from the video that
the animal is very calm and easy to work
with
and that animal had received no
anesthesia or analgesia
again
for the purposes of a non-surgical
embryo transfer there is no anesthesia
required
there's no post-surgical monitoring
after the procedure is done the animal
is simply returned to the cage and the
procedure is over
one of the most important things
from a technical standpoint is that
there's no surgical training required
for this procedure
learning the procedure is very easy um
it's not something that requires a lot
of technical training and can be very
quickly
implemented in your laboratory
the
non-surgical embryo transfer procedure
satisfies one of the three r's it's a
refinement of a technique it reduces
pain and distress
it's a terrific improvement for animal
welfare
it also reduces regulatory burden
the
need to explain why you need to use a
surgery and how the surgery is going to
be performed and all the
methods that are required to
prepare your lab for a surgical
procedure need not be performed
this is a non-uh
invasive well
non-surgical invasive procedure
it's extremely fast the procedure itself
only takes about a minute from start to
finish then that includes loading the
embryos into the device
which is much faster than trying to
perform a surgical procedure where the
post procedure monitoring even takes a
large chunk of your research day
it's extremely convenient
and there's a significant cost savings
involved especially if you need to
purchase surgical
materials an anesthesia machine
perhaps
training
technicians or researchers to do the
procedures
for a surgical procedure is very cost
intensive
whereas the non-surgical embryo transfer
procedure
is
much less expensive
so
in conclusion
i'd like to take a moment to acknowledge
a few people and
institutions that have helped with this
research
first of all the testing of the
non-surgical embryo transfer device for
esl injected molasses was performed
under contract at the the jackson
laboratory we'd also like to thank kim
kariko for her contributions towards
developing the eliza protocol
and mouse specifics
for their generous support regarding the
ecg e device and analysis of the data
this research is presented with support
from the office of the director national
institutes of health
under the award number award number
shown here and by the kentucky cabinet
for economic development office of
commercialization and innovation in
conjunction with the kentucky science
and technology corporation
i'd also like to thank our research team
for all their hard work kendra steele
james hester and angelica feth goodin
we're instrumental in performing these
experiments and collecting the data
this is a list of selected nsat
publications
i know that you can't read these here
very well but these references are also
found on the peritects website
if you have any
interest in pathogen transfer or
material transfer
those references are indicated on here
as well as the embryo transfer
references
and
i'd like to thank you all for joining me
today i'd be happy to take any questions
at this time
dr kendra steele from the research team
uh is joining me at right now and we'll
be uh able to help answer any questions
that have been submitted during the talk
during by the audience
and kendra
thanks barb yeah we have a few questions
i would like to ask that everyone keep
submitting those questions
um the first one is your artificial
insemination data looks promising could
you please share the details of that
protocol
um yeah
actually let me
get back to that
slide
and
all right
so here you can see that the pregnancy
rate for this artificial insemination
experiment here was approximately
36
i believe
and what was what was done here was um
in general terms
we superovulated the female that was
going to be the recipient of the sperm
and so
the
injections for superovulation are first
to inject with
pregnant mare serum gonadotropin
and then at a 47 hour interval then
injecting with
human chorionic gonadotropin okay and
these were both done at levels which
would normally be used for super
ovulation in a female and so that was at
five international units of both of
those hormones
and those hormone hormones were injected
first
at 8 30 pm for the first hormone and 8
pm at the second
injection time point
and then the following morning
sperm were delivered using the nsaid
device
from
b6 c3f1 males okay so
these males
were euthanized in the morning and the
sperm was capacitated for an hour and a
half
40 microliters of this fresh sperm was
transferred
with the unset device
and this occurred roughly at 9am on that
morning the females then were paired
with vasectomized cd1 males overnight
um
and this is because uh the copulatory
activity needs to occur in order for the
pregnancy to be established
and uh the pregnancy rate that we then
saw from that um
was 36 percent
um and it was uh i believe that we can
actually improve upon this um we're
working with the protocol right now to
make it happen but
it was a very
promising initial result
great okay
the next question is about the video is
the mouse and the video anesthetized and
kind of a follow-up to that aren't you
afraid of biting
the mouse in the video has not been
anesthetized
and is simply being held in a position
which tends to make the mouse freeze in
that position
and cd1 mice are very docile and easy to
handle and i've never been bitten by a
cd1 mouse doing this procedure
having said that some of the other
strains that we've
compared the cd1 mouse to
for pregnancy rate and
embryo transfer efficiency or birth rate
um have been less
happy about the procedure and so
um we do have methods in place in our
lab to work with less than cooperative
mice um and this only uh the only thing
that we do is that we wear heavier
gloves
and that seems to avoid any of the
problems but
the cd1 mice are very calm and easy to
use and we've never had any problems
with that
okay good
how can i best be trained to use the
unset procedure
um
training for non-surgical embryo
transfer it can be
minimal or if you have a lot of
experience with mice or
sometimes if you're uncomfortable with
the procedure itself it's helpful to
take a class in this so there are two
different things that we suggest first
of all if you are an expert at handling
animals and you're comfortable with
the procedure itself
i would suggest either
starting with euthanized animals
or
you can also
practice on
animals that have been anesthetized
and if you are going to try something
like that
make sure that the animal is indeed 2.5
days pseudo-pregnant
the opening of the cervix has to be
dilated in order for the insect device
to pass through and so if you try to do
this without
without having the animal dilated first
it won't work
um and so i would suggest definitely
practicing if you're new to this
procedure practicing a few times without
embryos
because ambrose are precious
and i'm getting the hang of working with
maybe
euthanized mice first
and then moving on to
animals that
i i don't think that the
anesthetized mice are really necessary
unless you're really uncomfortable with
it but
moving on to animals that are uh just
pseudo-pregnant in a live format and
you'll find that it's an extremely easy
procedure to perform
if
anybody is interested in being trained
personally in this method
we do perform
workshops uh every year uh
internationally and locally um and we
can also
uh
do workshops on site if anybody's
interested in that and so um
it's it's a very easy uh
it's a very easy procedure to learn
okay
do you offer free insect samples
oh um we do actually offer samples and i
believe that it we have a booth here on
in the um
bio conference live and uh you can
actually request a sample at the booth
or you can request a sample from the
paratex website
and that's all the questions we have for
now
oh all right
well thank you again everybody for
joining us
and uh if you do have any further
questions we will be available on the
booth uh at the in the um
um
area and if you would like to
contact us personally feel free to do so
all of our contact information is on the
peritects website and again thank you
very much for joining us